today's episode is brought to you by
square cash square cash is the best way
to pay people back friends family
coworkers ghosts a chair anyone really
sending and receiving money is totally
free and fast it's this fast in between
those two it's those that fast and most
payments can be deposited directly in
your bank account in seconds
download the free cash app for iOS or
Android was it beautiful hey alert
babies alert I'm back in LA and I was in
the pool that's how we do it in LA this
is the episode of 22 yeah wait wow man
we're really getting up there and I was
in the pool so that's all I really give
a [ __ ] about was in Miami was in was in
West Palm Beach was out in the Sun for
about an hour and now my shoulders are
this color of a goddamn tomato it hurts
and my mom texted me are you outside and
I wrote you up she wrote sunscreen
please made me BRM you can't escape your
mom you know what I mean that's just how
it is if we can't escape your mom unless
maybe your mom escaped you early on
it's a sad but look guys this episode of
congratulations is dropping a few mere
few hours before the worldwide release
of man on fire unmet flicks and that is
my comedy special it's about 65 minutes
so go ahead and watch that
and do a little back to back do a little
back to back you watch this you listen
to this congratulations podcast and then
you turn on Netflix and you wait you
wait for man on fire to drop on Netflix
then you press play and you make it a
Chris D'Elia Monday is what you do or a
crystally a Tuesday or crystally a
Wednesday or crystally a Tuesday or a
crystally a bond day if you want to make
up a new day because man on fire is
gonna be on available on Netflix
worldwide no matter where no matter what
time you want to watch it so and I'm
really excited about it and let me just
say since I'm always joking around I put
this on my snapchat and I put it on my
Instagram thank you to everybody who has
ever come to a show and thank you to
everybody who's ever supported me in any
way I will I've worked very hard on this
career and I've worked really I've
worked really hard on this act man on
fire and it's out now so have at it
enjoy and if you don't enjoy eat my dick
you know slowly no your your you can
have your opinion you know but I am
really proud of it so go watch it so
that was what that's what I'm excited
about this week and let's recap the week
last week I was in let's see so I
remember when I was sick and I did the
the podcast last week and it was [ __ ]
my voice was terrible I'm getting it
back as you can hear mm-hmm I'm getting
my back my voice about 80% it was a
little hard because I did a bunch of
shows in West Palm Beach and man let me
just say West Palm Beach it's a great
club it's awesome it's a big [ __ ]
Club it holds 600 people did five shows
there and the management is great
they're so good to me they're friends of
mine now and I just I love the way they
run their club they make you feel
special and they so go there even if
you're not going to see me if you're in
the West Palm Beach area they got great
acts and they got a cool little
our next door that you can go to that's
got great food and it's just a cool kind
of area there and so I had a great time
in West Palm Beach there are how about
the that well no before I even get into
that I had a host I cannot remember his
name like a piece of [ __ ] now what an
[ __ ] I am he was so soft-spoken he
would hang out with us in the green room
and I liked the guy the guy was a great
guy he's a really cool guy young guys
like 25 and he was so soft-spoken that I
said what to him 75 times and then I
just stopped saying what and I would be
like yeah okay okay okay and I hope that
that was a valid response but even the
waiter or waitress would come in and be
like hey and he was like can I get a
lemon I get lemon in the tea maybe like
what and then he wouldn't raise his
voice even a little bit louder hey he
was just cool he's one of those like
cool dudes he was very cool like you
could tell he gets laid probably a lot
and he moved to West Palm Beach for no
reason I said dude it was Creek West
Palm Beach I said this before it's like
The Truman Show and this guy the host
[ __ ] I'm so pissed I don't remember his
name I'm such a [ __ ] but he was
funny too
but he was like hey I used well he said
it like this he was like yeah I'm from
Virginia Beach and I moved to West Palm
Beach and I said why and he said I don't
know man and I was like I'll imagine I
said you just picked a place and he was
like pretty much I mean oh hey you're a
storybook character oh you're a guy oh
you're a guy that I've [ __ ] that
what's his name would play yeah who's
that guy in dude have it I never
remember [ __ ] names when I do this
[ __ ] podcast the hell's his name
who's the guy who's in the movie I don't
remember the name of god damn it
[ __ ] was his name to ask his
friend of them dick he's like shorter he
was in that [ __ ] movie that Sean Penn
produced
[Laughter]
now goddamn it he's handsome he's a he
was in that movie about the girl next
door with the Emile Hirsch for [ __ ]
sake anyway god damn well you know what
is there's a meal so it wasn't like John
Wright um at least I didn't forget it
anyway
I was in West Palm Beach and it was
heaven and I was having a great time in
West Palm Beach man I really had a good
time there I didn't expect much and I
think that's the key right because
that's why whenever we go to Las Vegas
it's a letdown
you're like bro we're gonna go we're
gonna bet we're gonna win BIC big we're
gonna get chicks we're gonna [ __ ] eat
the best food and then you go and you're
like where are my pants
it wasn't as fun because I couldn't find
my it's like The Hangover you know so
and the manager Justin in West Palm
Beach sent me a snapchat of iguanas
which is like crazy that the iguanas are
around and they're big and I was
thinking about how there's actual
alligators in how about the fact that
there are alligators in America and it's
America now like oh cool oh they're
monsters hey they are monsters if you
look at me and say no that's an
alligator I reply with no it's a monster
because it can crush your legs with its
jaw it has a huge tail and its scaly all
over and it has eyeballs that blink
sideways it's a monster okay hey
that have spiky scaly [ __ ] skin you
monster
it's a [ __ ] alligator and that's in
America and they're just they'll just be
in like [ __ ] swamps that's so weird
that that's in America if you think
about it
like it seems like something like an
alligator seems like something that
would be in like the this like South
America or like you know in Africa or
some somewhere else but they're in
Florida hey you have monsters in Florida
that's amazing
they have monsters that if you were
alone in a room with this thing you die
you don't live hey do you have a gun you
still die
you shoot the [ __ ] alligator four
times you still Prag gonna die if the
room small enough that's [ __ ] crazy
if they have monsters Heather's monsters
in the world did you guys know they're
alligators and you can get them in
America America has monsters I think
that's crazy how about being in iguana
and there are alligators that's [ __ ]
[ __ ] [ __ ] that's like damn dude I feel
like there are probably iguanas in in
like swamps that like lose their [ __ ]
to alligators you know like like it will
be like yeah man like the iguanas like
man watch out when you got your girl you
bring them around the alligators
alligators [ __ ] Ted will swoop your
[ __ ] up man how do you compete with
them alligators you know they're too big
the big-ass tails they can crunch
[ __ ] and swivel them around and
drown them in the swamps they're [ __ ]
straight-up monsters and they'll steal
your [ __ ] man
alligators just watch and laugh as
iguanas walk by look at that mother
[ __ ] [ __ ] ass egg iguana I'll steal
your [ __ ] keep walking don't sleep
[ __ ]
that's what alligators say we're not
wanders walked by with their [ __ ] don't
sleep and then blink sideways I don't
give a [ __ ] I know they bling up and
down but
still blink sideways they have that skin
under their eyeball under their eyes
their eyelid that blinks sideways and
even if they don't they do because
that's in my head it's real I love
[ __ ] III
their they don't they look they're scary
obviously because they're monsters but I
don't know man III never saw an
alligator so there was nothing none of
them were bought tickets to my my show I
I got I should have actually started the
podcast saying this guy's bought shorts
I know in the past here's the thing man
I know in the past over the few episodes
I probably talked about how dumb shorts
are because yeah you dolt
right you 7-eleven then don't wear
shorts and I kind of still mean that if
you were a cargo shorts if you got khaki
shorts
you got pinky got orange you got blue
shorts you seven or you nine but I got
these shorts that are jean shorts now
here's the deal I know when I say jean
shorts
everyone thinks at least some people
think well no jorts but i don't say
jords because that's a [ __ ] stupid
ass word I say jean shorts you don't
need to shorten everything just because
it's it's not a new thing it's still
shorts they're denim there's jean shorts
or just shorts you say jorts your
product to the system you want to be
product to the system or you want to be
independent that's that's a simple
question here I got for you you want to
be independent or you want to be product
to the system you want to be product to
the system say jorts all day long you
wanna be a free thinker shorts okay
you're not cute because you say jorts
you're just putting two words together
come up with a new word come up with a
new new thing call them you know flaw
Lee's don't call them shorts
you just stole two words and mush them
together
that's not cool I don't like when people
take two things and mush them together
period remember Inc it in school when
the kids used to rip the heads off the
gummy bears and make the gullet gummy
bears different colors I never did that
[ __ ] [ __ ] that you eat a red gummy bear
you're eating a red gummy bear you don't
[ __ ] around and put the green with the
red even if it's Christmas you don't
[ __ ] put the yellow with the clear
doesn't even look that much different
okay
they made the green gummy bear eat the
green gummy bear they made the white
gummy bear eat the white gummy bear they
made the red gummy bear heat the red did
I already say red no they made the thing
they did the work don't rip the heads
off and put them together like that jean
shorts and i got him and let me tell you
why i got him because it was 92 degrees
in florida but with the humidity it was
four thousand and sixty-five degrees
humidity sucks a dump in my mouth okay
humidity is awful Miami and [ __ ] in
Fort Lauderdale and all those great
places there they're great when the
weather is fine but mostly when the
humidity [ __ ] you feel like you're
walking through literally feel like
you're walking through a mouth you feel
like you're walking through a mouth hey
is this weather or am i walking through
Charles Barkley's mouth cuz that's how
hot it is in Charles Barkley's mouth
Miami is this Miami or is this Charles
Barkley's mouth that's what that's two
mainly I wanna look somebody I want to
walk all the way in Miami I should have
done this I didn't do it next time I go
to Miami I'm gonna stop I'm gonna ask
people hey dude excuse me I've got this
crazy question and this is serious this
is Miami right and then when they say
yes or they say yes because they're
probably foreign considered by foreign
isn't goddamn Miami and I say is this
okay school that that's actually cool
that this is Miami because I thought for
a goddamn second I'm gonna look him
right in the eyes and [ __ ] lower my
jaw and then put my two
hands out like Italians and I'm gonna
say I thought I was in Charles Barkley's
goddamn mouth and then they're not gonna
know what I mean because they're
probably French or some [ __ ] and then
they're gonna walk away dude it's
amazing how many people are it's
actually amazing one of the most amazing
things about Megami is how
okay like you know how white people
think it's hard to tell the difference
between a Japanese person and a Chinese
person sir a cyst white person okay
they look different I can tell the
difference between an American person a
white American and a white person from
London you can either just they look a
little bit different you can tell when
you see somebody's face not the kind of
thought no yes Ron cuz they got [ __ ]
you know a little bit of a different
thing they can look a little bit
different their faces move slightly to
the left or right a little bit
differently or they have really really
really high neon shorts on and a [ __ ]
backpack that's camouflage right but in
Miami that [ __ ] is all out the window
you can see a person that would just
look like an American dad and walk up
and be like hey man where's the
Starbucks and I'll be like douche look I
do Luke Luke Luke Luke Luke Luke and
you're like oh for [ __ ] sake sorry man
you just look like a [ __ ] guy named
Jordan douche look at him a douche look
like now and you're like oh my god and
then his wife comes like that aru no
bloosh looked up and then their kid
and then they [ __ ] walk away you know
I got him he just looked like a regular
guy named Dave oh yeah this Starbucks
he's down street down the street to the
left do you make a you make a fuck-boy
what I'm sorry no no you make a right
down the street to the right and then to
the Starbucks your [ __ ] boy
okay I think the foreign guy just called
me a [ __ ] boy what is it about Europeans
where they just gotta wear so much neon
dude they were so much neon and polo
shirts for days dude if you lined up all
of the polo shirts that one European
family had it would reach halfway to
Pluto
they'd [ __ ] wear polo shirts like
they're in Mars and need needed to
breathe like it's a [ __ ] spacesuit
like if there was a movie about a
European guy and he didn't have a polo
shirt on I'd be like this is so [ __ ]
unrealistic and more so than they wear
neon they have shirts with numbers on
them so much dude not sports shirts
they'll just wear like I have a [ __ ]
polo shirt with like a nine on it what
for man hey what for Hans hey Wolfgang
what's that number four what is it your
eighth polo shirt this week the [ __ ] are
they wearing neon shorts for with a polo
shirt that has the number 40 on it now
[ __ ] you doing Hans hey Hans the [ __ ]
you doin that's that shirt for you play
on a team no oh you're just an
investment banker on vacation take it
off put on a t-shirt with numbers on it
and take off that [ __ ] green they're
bright green shorts and put on a speedo
straight up I'm actually a fan of
speedos if you were a speedo you're a
[ __ ] you're the [ __ ]
what's with
number there was high up - I used to
make fun of my buddy Mitch Mitch had
this [ __ ] shirt I love this guy he
had a shirt on that had a [ __ ] like
six on it or something and it was so
high up it like we didn't look like it
was like normal on the on the like the
left breast or whatever a number would
be you know it was so high up and we'd
always be like why is that [ __ ] sick
so high do it and we would always
[ __ ] put our hand above the shoulder
and say like why is the number this high
what look look hey Who am I and we put
our hand above the shoulder probably
would [ __ ] laughed so hard we cry we
would be [ __ ] the idiots man it was
like we were so high but I was never
high but Mitchell was always high man
one time Mitch made me laugh so so
[ __ ] hard he listens to the podcast I
think so what's up Mitch and one time we
were at a diner and we were hanging out
with a bunch of people and guys and
girls and he was laughing and yeah he
would always talk about how his like he
laughed and he he'd always talk about
how he was feminine a little bit I mean
he's not really but the key would be
like yeah I'm feminine like he would say
that [ __ ] sometimes because he like
cared about people you know not because
like he was like swishy or whatever but
he would laugh and he would laughing and
put his shoulders up because he would
laugh and like it was like really like
you know like a bit [ __ ] you know and he
[ __ ] did it once while we were all
laughing and he put his index finger on
one of his shoulders and pushed it down
manually and said get down you and we
[ __ ] pissed ourselves with his high
[ __ ] six shirt on man he went get
down you like he I bawled his shoulder
put his index finger and pushed it down
manually and said get down you and I
[ __ ] screamed at the Coral cafe in
Burbank California why did I go there oh
man foreigners in Miami dude
unbelievable always walking around with
their scrunched up faces looking up why
everything's level why are you looking
to high up you're looking in the clouds
everything's down here bud oh man
monsters and Europeans you know Florida
that's Florida for you monsters swamps
and Europeans that's a reality show
right there why isn't there a reality
show just called Florida
we've got Europeans swamps and monsters
every week we vote one European or
monster off of our island off of our
Peninsula please tune in and see who
wins
Europeans versus monsters last Tuesday
Hans got his number ripped off by a
monster alligator let's see if Hans can
survive without his polo shirt I don't
think I can do it because I know my
whole life that I have worn my polo
shirt but I think you know I don't need
the number what I need is is a belief a
belief system and I believe I can do
this
if I put my mind to it and kind of it
all of the monsters now I know my my son
Wolfgang has been eaten by a monster
alligator and my wife is crying and she
has been crying in the small swamp
therefore thought week and a half since
last show but if we really put our
European heads together I believe we can
win this today now let's cut to some
audio video of an alligator I think I
think I think I just eat the European
I'll be fine
I'll get her [ __ ]
I don't know everything in Miami they
talk about everything in Miami is so
[ __ ] Miami I was there one day by the
way and West Palm Beach for the rest of
the time was Palm Beaches got to be the
[ __ ] richest area of all time I
bought a bathing suit and they were like
that'll be your that'll be your two back
tires on your car
that's how much it costs hi thank you
yeah let me ring you let me ring you up
that'll be two back tires I'm sorry
that'll be your two back tires if you
want this if you want this bathing suit
the I'm sorry this mating suit costs my
two back tires yes why because we know
that that they were 750 dollars together
so we're just gonna sell him after that
and make more money so if you want this
suit that's what's up
um you know it's really expensive there
because this retirement community
probably everybody there was so old
everybody there was sold they were like
I was seven years old I was seven they
talked to me like this hey hi they
talked to me like that because they
thought I was [ __ ] a boy lost looking
for his mom hi boy are you lost
no I'm just tryin to get a coffee Oh
where's his mommy where's his mommy um
so yeah but they came out but do we had
some [ __ ] old heads though they're in
the front row at the 7 p.m. show on
Saturday why did they come you know
[Music]
good food - food [ __ ] when I don't like
when people say they're foodies by the
way I feel like people like saying
they're a foodie more than they like
food if you like if you're truly like
food just eat the food you don't have to
have a [ __ ] term for it
like jorts oh you're a foodie nah you
know what you are you piggy oh you like
to eat so much oh you like to eat all
the different places oh you're a foodie
math scratch that you're fat pig
you fat Peggy I'm a foodie people love
telling you they're foodies
chicks chicks love it I'm because I'm a
foodie so I just like I love to
experience different cuisines and I love
culinary the culinary experience by I
love the co no but I love the culinary
experience excuse me step out a little
bit for a second gunk that's the door no
back up a little bit behind the door
where the door closes the gunk that's
the door shutting oh no that's fine
I just love their culinary experience oh
you do excuse me ma'am back up
gunk it's cute I just got it but what
are you doing I love the culinary Gong
[Laughter]
know but I'd love to try those little
did the snail the escargot I love
because I love because I'm a foodie gong
mmm excuse me now you're just saying how
I cook gong you like food I want you to
Rick excuse me ma'am yes I'm still out
here okay I have a question for you
are you fat piggy well no I don't think
I'm a fat piggy I mean I'm quite skinny
I was just trying to say that I
absolutely live and die for cuisine and
the cook gunk why do you keep sending
the door me because you don't know what
you truly are
the dung I mean come on dude just stop
making up new words just say what you
[ __ ] do and be real about it okay
I mean with the doors closed
that's what it's doing but then when you
slow it down gunk that's what it is man
shot my [ __ ] door in your face shut
my door in your face yeah dude I mean
[ __ ] you can say whatever you want free
conch but if you say you're a foodie
cook dunk all right
you can say what you want free conch but
if you say you like the culinary
experience good gunk I'm sorry dude you
[ __ ] brought it on yourself
you don't want a [ __ ] wall in your
face then just say you like food or
you're a fat piggy then yeah okay but if
you say you are a foodie gunk now are
you wearing shorts are you wearing
shorts good gunk I'm sorry that's how it
is if you want to be a part of this
[ __ ] cult and you're wearing [ __ ]
jean shorts swatch you're wearing if
you're wearing shorts yaddam occult and
[ __ ] gunk that's my PSA for today babies
don't get all hyped up in the [ __ ]
you know with the sauce
don't get all hyped up with the sauce
words to live by
so anyway yeah [ __ ] culinary
experiences and [ __ ] I can't even watch
sometimes I can't even watch those those
things I you know I think I talked about
this on part when I did beat Bobby Flay
I minded the episode of be profile of
[ __ ] Bobby Flay he's [ __ ] awesome
I did one of those episodes I was one of
those judges on there you know for what
for an episode for an episode and he and
I was like you know what I'm gonna say I
told my agent I was like
I'm gonna say I can't wait to do this
I'm gonna say this the sauce or the salt
or whatever I was gonna use the word I
would say that's that's just a vehicle
for the salmon or whatever the [ __ ] you
know and as soon as I sat down [ __ ]
you're not Bobby Flay one of the first
words that came out of his mouth well
it's just a vehicle for the bread or
whatever the [ __ ] I was like there
goes my whole [ __ ] thing unbelievable
you know how many times they say vehicle
in when it comes to food
why are you talking automobiles hey
Wheaton pizza why are you talking
automobiles good gunk why are you
[ __ ] talking automobiles we eaten
pizza why are you talking to automotive
cook gunk now if you want to say hey
also I like the way it tastes you know
I'm 37 it's the best part about any of
it I'm gonna have a kid one day and
maybe and they [ __ ] are gonna you
know I mean listen all the [ __ ] they're
gonna be a daddy was a [ __ ] dunk I don't
know hmm I don't know
hey guys uh you know what look I want to
talk to you about how this this thing
here okay what did you sit back and when
you listen you know I'm not a drinker if
you're if you if you ever hear me talk
you know I'm not a drinker and it
doesn't mean I don't like to entertain
okay I got guests that come over and
when my guests can have great wine and I
don't have to worry about what I'm
buying
I'm happy all right but tell you about a
company called wink WI and see they give
you access to exceptional wines from
around the world just go to try wink
calm spelled T ry WI and see calm and
take a brief palette profile quiz and
wink will recommend distinct and
interesting wines actually customized to
your palate to be shipped directly to
your door every month sounds like a good
idea to me none of your time is wasted
filling out a none of your time is
wasted fitting in a run at the store
right or on you don't have to go on your
way home from
or any way to an event or gathering you
know you got to go sometimes to a party
like oh let's pick up something you're
not to do that anymore you have to get
you know if they guess what you might
like wink basis the wines and they sent
they sent them to your taste preferences
alright they'll also introduce you to
new rare and customized that are not
available anywhere else that and they'll
tell you the story behind you want each
one if you're a wine guy it's a great
thing to get into join for free skip any
month cancel anytime and they have a
hundred percent satisfaction guarantee
so you'll never pay for a bottle you
don't like right now wink is offering
listeners 20% off your first order when
you go to try winked calm / Congrats
they're leaving cover the cost of
shipping
that's tri wink spelled T ry winc comm /
congrats to get 20% are $20 off your
first order now + complimentary shipping
try wink calm / Congrats go square cash
square cash is the best way to pay
people back friends family co-workers
rugs a wall and it doesn't matter what
race you are you'd be black white asian
Indian doesn't matter sending and
receiving money is totally free and fast
and most payments can be deposited
directly into your bank account in
seconds all right here's how it works if
you're an idiot
here's how it works I'll explain it to
you download the square cash app link
your debit or credit card select an
amount to send and type in a friend's
phone number or email address to
complete a payment what but there's got
to be more Chris but there isn't though
person who's talking to me they'll get a
notification that they've just received
money that's it there's no gimmicks
Square cash is the [ __ ] it's awesome
it's not a social network all right you
on Facebook get Facebook you want to
send money get square cash and once
their payments listed in a feed
I don't neither do you download the free
square cash app for iOS or Android now
that's for that ad that's for that ass I
had to do that now excuse me I had to do
some ads because I had to hear beep beep
beep from the Brinks truck dude alright
you want you want to know what music to
my ears is beep beep beep from the
Brinks truck backing
into my garage opening up the back of
the truck and unloading a pool of money
you don't want me to do that you want
free content now if you want free
content go work for free
this dude Eric O'Neill on my West Palm
Beach show made me a shirt that said
back her actually don't know if he made
that one but he may do another one
called succinylcholine and I wore it on
stage and he lost his [ __ ] mind
because of the one of the episodes I
don't know if you guys heard that
episode but I was talking about Forensic
Files and how the guy always says
succinylcholine succinylcholine that's a
kiss for your babies so somebody else I
don't know if I was him it might have
been him I think it might've been
someone else they wrote they did a shirt
that said back up the Brinks truck and
it was awesome I gotta wear that one too
it's really cool so yeah or the Dunbar
somebody to you me so somebody on the
minimum list um one of those minimalist
guys tweeted me today what do you do if
you're if the Brinks truck is all is all
full you get a bigger Brinks truck I
said yeah or I get a Dunbar truck bro I
used that red and black I backed out red
and black up okay you think I just go
white and blue all back red and black up
as well as long as I'm hearing beep beep
beep somewhere near our garage man on
fires out if you're probably listening
to this because I mean unless you really
listen to it unless you're a true baby
and you heard it as soon as it dropped
uh yeah and I'll be in LA performing in
the next few weeks
trying to [ __ ] get my voice back
about 80% still can't hit them high
notes well actually I can't Khan
[Music]
I didn't mean to get I'm sorry that I
got so [ __ ] soulful on your ass right
there real quick but I just wanted to
test the high notes
I know I know sorry I got so [ __ ]
soulful on you I'm sorry that literally
Luther and Rose probably woke up from
the dead little bit for a second while I
hid those [ __ ] croonin ass high notes
but had to had to check no but so I'm
trying to save my voice but I'm doing so
many of these [ __ ] podcasts and [ __ ]
and interview radio interviews I did a
radio interview on KTLA it's always
weird in those news Luton news
interviews because all those newscasters
and [ __ ] they got that smile where you
can just hear it I feel like if you get
close enough to a newscaster when you're
talking and when they're waiting to say
what their next question is I feel like
if you got close enough you'd hear them
B you'd hear them smiling like this you
know because they're just it's hurts
because they're just always smiling
they're like so talk to me a little bit
about the new special and then you're
talking and then if you get close enough
you just hear them like this okay
where'd you film it and then you're
talking about where'd you film it and
they're just uh huh so I did that but
I'm doing lot of podcast so I'm still
keeping the voice scratchy doing it real
sexy I don't mean I don't mean look
ladies local ladies I'm sorry my voice
is so raspy I'm sorry my voice is so
raspy but my suggest is if you listen to
this if you listen to this podcast and
if you listen to it in your cubicle you
listen to it in your car just put a
towel down I'm sorry but I gotta I had
to yell out my voice and now it's really
raspy and I'm really sorry put a towel
down I don't mean a snail your [ __ ]
chair up
and gross but necessary
I've got to be saying these things put a
towel down you know you should do you
should put down you know when you take
your car in for like a service and then
it has that floor mat just take that
with you next time you got to listen to
this podcast or the one before that
because my voice was so raspy and so
goddamn sexy
put that floor mat down put it right
down right under your butt drive with it
sit in your cubicle with it cuz you're
gonna get wet so not sexy a guy huh you
know what the I've always said this and
it's true I mean I don't you know I
think a lot of people believe this but
the second a guy thinks he's being sexy
or tries to be sexy he's not sexy like
that's the thing about it the difference
between sexiness and a girl and sexiness
with a guy if you're a girl you can be
sexy and try you can be like then you
can bend over or you can [ __ ] whip
your hair back or you could touch your
lips you can roll your titties up you
know what I mean
guys will just be idiots like there are
and do a squirty boner but if you're a
guy and you're like watch how I walk
[ __ ] into the room watch how I walk
into this goddamn room watch how slow my
[ __ ] gate is and how cool my cadence
is when I say hello to everybody you're
not sexy because you're trying there's a
fine line I mean you don't wanna be a
[ __ ] geek but you know even if you're
a geek a hardcore geek some of these
[ __ ] geek girls like you now you say
geeky too much like I just did you get
your tongue tied but they did it anyway
yeah don't think you're sexy
don't be sexy if you're a guy just be
[ __ ] chillin put on a shirt put on
some pants do what you got to do but
don't [ __ ] try bro you dry it all up
trying to have sex with a girl trying to
have sex
with you know some sandpaper
sorry I've officially don't know what
I'm talking about
I went 40 minutes strong and now I don't
know what I'm talking about but that's
what happens with the
stream-of-consciousness [ __ ]
you know haven't had any guests yet for
22 episodes I'll probably have guests at
some point I don't know I'm not sure yet
I don't want to have to rely on other
people that's the thing I already got to
rely on this [ __ ] producer right here
and sometimes he doesn't show up one
fighter but I don't because he helps me
out he does lots of stuff for me now
does he travel with me and when I have
to do the podcast on Mondays when I'm on
the road no one fire yeah sometimes does
he have a different thing that he had to
do and can't show up to do the podcast
even when he's in LA yeah now one fire
but don't the gunk but still but I
[ __ ] love I love the support that
everybody's been given me and everyone's
helping out tweeting about the podcast
my new special drops it dropped or it
dropped probably dropped already if
you're listening poppy dropped already
and onto the next dude on to the next on
on to the next I got some new material
working out now God have the new
material by the time this [ __ ]
special comes out because everyone's
gonna see it that's a fan of mine
Savannah and they're gonna come to see
me in like Montreal or if you know
Montclair which is how you're supposed
to say it if you're French on the 27th
and they're gonna be like oh I saw you
know I saw a lot of this so I'm trying
to build up the material got about 25
minutes and I'm vamping a lot I'm doing
a lot of crowd work to get some new
material I like doing crowd work
sometimes when you hackle want to kick
your face off but you know what I'm
talking about
[Music]
yeah so
yeah man so excited about the new
special and the fan art that people have
been doing is really funny to me a lot
of people been drawing pictures and [ __ ]
or photoshopping like my face with
denzel's on it or some somebody drew a
tired eagle some people try to draw
tired Eagles or just drawing me on fire
or something it's been funny and I've
been reposting those on Instagram and
Twitter and stuff so you know here we go
alright I'm gonna check out these
mentions here or the the I'm gonna check
the hashtags the congratulations pod
hashtag let's run through them how long
does it take this is from nicholas m @
nicolò Gnaeus not bad how how long does
it take after you throw it you're set to
have a new hour you're ready to tour
with well I just kind of answered that
question yeah it should be a few months
before I get a new hour but it won't be
you know I'll be kind of trying to [ __ ]
with it it'll be a lot of a lot of
working it but you know I worked this
one for like a year and a half I saw by
the way it's somebody online that was
like oh great can't believe somebody was
on the special I posted a trailer to my
special and they were like I can't
believe I I saw you live and I saw you
do these jokes live man seriously hey
man do you know how it works we think
you just write some [ __ ] the night of
the time you're shooting it takes
[ __ ] at least a year to do it
so obviously you saw it because it was
in your town
oh boy this guy somebody's alerting me
Stu at real Stu 69 change it 100% 69 is
not cool bro shrill dorky did you see
this Papa Smurf chain that costs $75,000
rich the kid is a rapper I guess okay
that's a Papa Smurf diamond chain and
that's the guy talking about it wow
that's real bad you know use the $75,000
for something else and that's 100%
amazingly obvious can you comment on
grown men that bring their glove to
baseball games Dom Hinton aka or at aka
Dom yeah I mean that's actually it's
funny that these people are asking the
questions that they know that I would
maybe touch on
I like that means Y on the right path
and you part them called if you bring
your goal adult if you bring your glove
to a baseball game and you have no
children with you of course
burn it because you're not gonna catch
something first of all because you're
just in the stands and also if it comes
at you miraculously use your [ __ ]
adult hand okay but if you have a kid
and you're like let's bring blows to the
game that's cute
kind of all bets are off if you have a
kid's kind of in a way you can do
anything
kind of yeah so a lot of these people
are just talking about Logan cane at
logo - change it thoughts on sneak on
streakers at sporting events well yeah
man I mean don't show your dick in
public by the way I was listening to
that prodigy song
keep it thorough and because also
listening because prodigy died last week
which was a shame man he was really
young and when he and I was listening to
the album just to kind of like things
like you know reminisce on his [ __ ]
amazing career and that line one of my
favorite lines from prodigy how does it
when he says how does it feel to hold my
dick in public like it's so funny and
good and and then when he says I'll
throw a TV at you crazy like so basic
but also sit to the point and also say
hip-hop so Oh anyway a lot of people are
saying that they're staying up to watch
the pot the special I'll be on you know
I'll be hanging I'll be awake so if
you're gonna do that that's really cool
tweet me man on fire tweet me that [ __ ]
and let me know I'll be watching check
in maybe yeah I mean I think I'll be up
checking but whatever and I'm really uh
I don't know and oh I forgot to talk
well I don't know if there so I need to
talk about but the [ __ ] what's the
deal with Joe Budden why is he so mad I
I watched the thing at the BT Awards
just a little clip of me ghosts and how
he was like first of all the fun
nobody's talking about the funniest part
of that interview was how they the
[ __ ] the interviewer had no [ __ ]
clue what those guys were saying for a
little bit I mean there was like the guy
would say like nah but what did about
talk about bad abou G and I guess that
what whatever wooden table by the baddie
bougie hey he literally went hey like
siddik yeah but that's what I would have
done hey man you're you're doing an
interview at least try to say the things
so I'll understand them that I'm mad
about the bougie
hey the guy went and then Joe Budden was
so pissed that he just my I we got to
wrap this up and then he [ __ ] put
through the mic down and walked away and
then they squared up on him dude the
three migos I mean they were all dressed
like [ __ ] ants houses like [ __ ] my
like my aunt and uncle's house with the
[ __ ] they dress like a couch and a
and and some curtains had had had a kid
and like they were gonna fight him I
mean so funny I guess I don't even know
but it was like I don't understand why
Joe Budden was being such a dick Joe
Budden seems mad dude seems like a guy
how much would Joe Budden love his
girlfriend to like that's the kind of
thing that would be like such a dick and
so mad but then be like that's my queen
though yeah I don't know why he's so mad
he's always so mad though he had a
[ __ ] battle with like a he had made a
song who was it that was he was a long
time ago he came at Drake yeah thing was
Drake whatever I don't know all I know
is I think Joe Budden's [ __ ] handsome
bro it's all I got on Joe Budden and and
he came out with that [ __ ] song buh
buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh buh but
pull up up up up pump it up I loved that
song Feeny mmm
that was [ __ ] awesome that song that
song reminded me of the song that would
even though it was before this one the
LL Cool J song head sprung that one to
me they call me big la big pill a big
chale big Sal a big chili Benefield's in
a pill a got a ball and a Mose and the
cats keep your head sprung gotta get
your head sprung said nothing so far
they call me Big L a Big Chill a big Sal
a big play
you're gonna bits and a pause and the
cat's gonna whippin and a pause and the
Jets nothing love it so dope
loved that song um big la did they ever
call him big la big Sally has anyone
ever heard LL Cool J call him big Sally
hey excuse me big Sally oh yeah oh la
cosa
yeah what's up that's what they call me
big Shelly when I'm whippin at the walls
with my cats they call me big I mean
look at the [ __ ] rap what it what the
[ __ ] this is what the internet says he
says they call me Big L why it's so
[ __ ] robotic they call me Big L Y WH
hi big silly big money big Billy
don't don't don't don't they call me Big
O I big silly big money big bill a no no
no when I'm sliding in the mall came
here may I be second with this bar so if
the mayor let me group it in occurs in
the back let me give in a buzz in your
head
i'ma tell you have a cars in the tech
Tamlyn little is live in a track
hey what dude that's cool but real quick
hey and [ __ ] I thought migos they call
me big ly what if that's how you wrapped
it they call me big ly big silly big
money big Billy when I'm sliding in them
K all can you hear me
I'd be sexing with these bars so you
feel me let me grip it up for cause in
the back let me grip it in a buzz in
your hat I'm gonna tell you how to cause
an attack
Timberland ladies love on the track dude
would be so bad but if you run it
together it's the [ __ ] they come Big M
ahead big Sal a big man a big blare when
I'm sliding the marquee he made a
particular just buzzin for the mayor I
love how the [ __ ] rap God or whatever
this was got it wrong I said let me grip
it up for cause in the back it's cuz
probably not the axle and I don't mean
because let me rip it up for because in
the back
so white whoever made it big hello I so
dumb like he's asking the question
himself they call me big out why and
they're just like no keep rappin okay
big silly big money big Billy making it
up as he goes along we got to start now
go go we have to start now they want the
album yesterday okay ding-ding they call
me Big M a big cell a big bully big
silly I'm gonna group it in the cars in
the back he said is this good just keep
going doesn't matter we got a dope beat
named man I love hip-hop dude it's so
funny I like hip-hop because I like to
think that there are a hundred percent
serious about it once it started getting
a little silly and they knew it I liked
it a little bit less you know but in in
like the early 2000s when when the
rappers thought for real I'll [ __ ]
shoot you I'll [ __ ] you up and these
these lyrics are [ __ ] hot fire not
silliness that was the [ __ ] because it
was even funnier but when you got these
guys who think they're being cute and
funny and it's all about their image and
it's all about getting meme Don it's
less funny because they know what
they're doing you know they took rap
they took hip-hop and made out what the
[ __ ] they made it the [ __ ] funniest
[ __ ] and then they were like oh this is
why it's funny and now you got [ __ ]
you know Hannah Montana Hannah Montana
Hannah Montana Hannah Montana that's a
song by me goes bad but they meant to
make it like that
you think it's ill by can we play this
on the part I don't
that is worth decided the [ __ ] thing
that doesn't have it well I think I have
this song you guys know that song had
sprung if you don't let's listen to them
I'm sure it's okay for the head sprung
just for a few and angry why would it
not be playing what it says it's playing
am I hooked up to like Bluetooth or some
[ __ ] why would it not be playing why
do they do this an apple does it work
with other songs Apple come on dude they
call you big la Apple dude did they call
you big la bill what a bit big Sally why
would it not be playing oh and a lot
wouldn't electronics don't work bro it
makes me angry don't have them invented
if they don't work well you're gonna
have to look up that song but no that's
not what he said all those things are so
wrong that all those things are so wrong
and play it and I'll play it [ __ ] 20
minutes later why you know because of
the internet that's why so he definitely
doesn't say they call me big he says la
[Music]
actually I think that was kind of right
but not not I think that was right I
don't know whatever anyway yeah that's
it that's all I got to say for this week
you know you guys are [ __ ] great
thanks for all the support and you know
how I always tell you to [ __ ] hashtag
there's this pond and tell your [ __ ]
friends about it and download it and
[ __ ] I still want you to do that but
here is the moment that my special comes
out is the moment my special comes out
and I'd love it if you guys [ __ ]
watched it and if you don't you know
then alright fine but tell your friends
about it get the word out there [ __ ]
put out put it out there Chris D'Elia
hashtag man on fire listen to it or
watch it up on Netflix and I'm real
proud of it a lot of hard work went into
it and there was something else I wanted
to say and I don't remember and I won't
remember it until I'm done recording and
it'll be extra mad so I guess I don't
have to wait till next week but I
definitely don't remember what it was oh
well thanks for listening and keep rate
and review the podcast and there's
enough leaks even have a thumbs I think
it only has a thumbs up thing anymore so
it sums up my thing I don't give a [ __ ]
what am I even saying you know just a
[ __ ] piece of [ __ ]
yeah thumbs up my thing [ __ ] great
review whatever you [ __ ] want to do
do but you know we don't like admiration
or whatever so thanks for listening this
has been [ __ ] Chris D'Elia they call
me big cell a big chale big la big gelée
and when you whip it in the malls with
your cats I'm second on these bars with
your bats okay are using square cash yet
download the free square cash app for
iOS or Android now I'm gonna be in
Montreal soon Albuquerque New Mexico you
live there who are you I'm going to be
in Austin I'm gonna be in all sorts of
different
places I'm gonna be in North Carolina
I'm gonna be in all sorts of [ __ ]
places in Utah because go check it out
and man on fire comes out it is out it
is out so go listen to it or so go watch
it on Netflix it sound like a nine year
old man go listen to it on Netflix tweet
me at hashtag congratulations pot and
rate review the show iTunes Google Play
stitcher now what people tweet me pay
one's gonna be available on Google Play
or stitcher I get blood red math so it's
on there already a goal most importantly
watch man on firing and tell your
friends thank you guys
you guys put a plain and simple from the
babies and this is the best cult of ever
thank you
[Music]